hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday [ __ ] February 24 rude
phowa route 24 go down to Brockton
what's going on
how are you how are you how's it going
in your world that's [ __ ] great sorry
I usually try not to be sophomoric I
just tried to be [ __ ] silly but
anyway let's let's get on with the
podcast ie once again have another
[ __ ] early day tomorrow Grande Ronde
problem I remember I'm just trying to
make it too much all right let's let's
right out of the gate I just want to
address something that you know it was
really [ __ ] annoying this [ __ ] out of
me
so this [ __ ] guy right he was a flat
earther which I gotta be honest with you
where did these people come from who you
know it was proven like we were flat
earthers and then somebody finally said
wait a minute it's it's round and then
the church decided to kill the guy right
oh no way he when he said the Sun was
the center of the [ __ ] solar system
and it's like know what the earth is we
are because God made us like in his
[ __ ] thing his image right wasn't
something like that I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know but anyway we kind of
sailed around it pointed in one
direction and came back on the other
side and these guys are trying to I
don't understand why what is the benefit
to lying what is the endgame we have to
tell them it's round man why I get all
the other ones saying that money has
value saying these people are evildoers
saying these people just want to give it
to the poor saying these people just
want to keep all the money I get
I understand the motives in that I just
don't know what is what is flat earthers
let me ask you this
flat flat earthers are the same people
that would watch one of those [ __ ]
Netflix documentaries and like you know
I don't think that guy did it and a
buddy of mine one time [ __ ] he
watched that stupid curtain in Courtney
Love documentary and by the end of it
they had convinced him that Courtney
Love killed Kurt Cobain and I was
sitting there going through do you
really think that a [ __ ] drug addict
from three states away [ __ ] organized
a hit in the Seattle Police Department
couldn't figure that out haven't you
watched the first 48 you ever see a
mobster on that now you see a bunch of
[ __ ] dopes who killed somebody for
the first time getting caught anyway
why the [ __ ] would she kill him he he
wrote her whole album makes no sense so
flat-earthers
I don't understand can somebody explain
to me cuz I'll be honest with you I
don't know if the earth round okay any
more than anybody else does all these
[ __ ] people are going dude you look
more it's world you're doing that you're
you you know it's round not cuz you
figured it out
alright you know it's round because
somebody told you it was round everybody
acting like they [ __ ] built their own
steam rocket went out in the [ __ ] air
well you took a flight to Disneyland and
that's what you would check it out you
wouldn't even checking it out I'll tell
you this right now when you when you
when you fly it when you actually fly
commercial you can't tell it the earth
is round I think if you're sitting up
front you can you can't look out the
side of the [ __ ] thing I don't know
what you see but I don't see anything
that says it's definitely flat or it's
definitely [ __ ] round I know it's
[ __ ] round
because the goddamn astronauts who have
[ __ ] balls you know that have been
you know you know looks [ __ ] that
guys come back from space and the whole
thing everything burns up you know if
they [ __ ] up everything that the design
[ __ ] everything burns up we except for
the balls of the person on that [ __ ]
thing yeah they took the pictures and
like well there it is there it is I've
never tried to sail around the world you
know and looked at my compass to make
sure I was still headed west and I kept
heading west and all of a sudden I was
back in my driveway again all right I'm
just like you I know it's round because
smarter people figured it out people
died and then they [ __ ] told me what
was right okay and I choose to believe
it I've flown around the world not all
at once
but you know I slept for a lot of it how
do I know he didn't [ __ ] turn around
[Music]
so this gets me to this Team Rocket guy
sorry I'm drinking tea I'm an old man
here all right so this [ __ ] guy
rather than just being like you and me
who just accept what these [ __ ]
people tell us is true all right and
know that know that you know that it's
[ __ ] round because somebody taught
you that not because you figured it out
the amount of [ __ ] [ __ ] on social
media the way they're going off on this
Team Rocket guy about cuz he believed
the world was flat these [ __ ]
[ __ ] who've never accomplished
anything in their [ __ ] life like let
me ask you okay so this [ __ ] guy if
you don't know the story he builds a
[ __ ] steam rocket which I don't even
know how the [ __ ] you do that I have no
idea how to do that this guy knew how to
do that he got himself into it when it
took off I guess the parachute ripped
off and he was flying all the way up
into the [ __ ] air which by the way I
don't know what radio call you make in
aviation that you're gonna [ __ ] do
that be a reverse lawn dart and just go
straight up in the [ __ ] air I guess
they were filming a TV show so I would
like to think some producer called
somebody to make sure they work
hit a [ __ ] commercial flight with
[ __ ] 400 people on it 300 people on
it right so he shoots up in the air the
parachute comes off you don't feel like
right now I feel like one of those
[ __ ] YouTube stars you know how they
always do these intros that you just
don't need it's like I just want to see
the video like you know I believe this
okay so these [ __ ] guys go to steam
rocket right like how do you make that
just show the [ __ ] guy taking off
right sorry it's a podcast so I guess I
get away with it so the [ __ ] thing
takes off
very impressive velocity something flies
off it evidently it was the parachute he
got up there okay into being in all
fairness this guy for all I know he
proved that the world was [ __ ] flat
with his goddamn pictures I've never
been as high up as this guy when
allegedly you know I've never checked it
all out all right I went into a science
class they told me it was [ __ ] round
so I said yeah it's round so I would
pass the [ __ ] test so I didn't have
to go to [ __ ] summer school but I
know I never fact-checked it you know
this post me to era was supposed to vet
everything this guy's venting [ __ ] right
so he [ __ ] shoots up in the air the
goddamn parachute comes off and I guess
I I don't know if he knew it at the time
I hope he didn't know it
so remember he was up there on the way
up he had a good time took some selfies
when he was excited that he proved that
it was flat and then he was coming all
the way back down I can't believe the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna get now that I'm
the guy that [ __ ] told caperna sit
Copernicus is that the guy to go [ __ ] to
Magellan to go [ __ ] himself
Santa Maria and he [ __ ] they died so
what happens what does everybody do
everybody goes on the internet and they
start [ __ ] laughing at this guy
talking about this guy like he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] people who are in a
[ __ ] cubicle who don't have a dream
who aren't leaders who've never made
anything [ __ ] happen in their life
not even a [ __ ] lemonade stand
all right this isn't that judging this
guy and they're doing that you know
Darwinism and [ __ ] you know the whole
[ __ ] whatever that stupid nature
thing is where it's like
this this what did the [ __ ] is that the
strongest people survive you know
natural selection in all of this [ __ ]
let me ask all you [ __ ] [ __ ] that
are making fun of this guy who had balls
of [ __ ] steel let me ask you this
who's smarter I actually asked my wife
this a guy who thinks the world is flat
and builds a steam rocket that shoots
himself up into the [ __ ] air and he
dies or the guy who doesn't know how to
build a steam rocket and doesn't get in
it and doesn't really [ __ ] do
anything in life other than not die
until he just croaks of old age who's
who's [ __ ] smart are you just smarter
cuz you're still alive I mean he [ __ ]
up he might have [ __ ] brilliant
people even always [ __ ] astronauts
who died trying to get [ __ ] orbit the
earth and all of that [ __ ] do you think
they're [ __ ] morons I mean
everybody's like um there should be no
[ __ ] do-it-yourself
[ __ ] you know rocket [ __ ] thing or
whatever the hell they say it's just
like why not NASA's had the exact same
[ __ ] problems and it costs the
taxpayers billions of dollars when this
[ __ ] blows up god bless this guy he did
a start I lost no money on that one
alright and he was trying to do
flat-earthers a solid and then all of
these [ __ ] [ __ ] you might be one of
those [ __ ] sitting there laughing at
this [ __ ] guy you want to laugh at
him I get it it's kind of funny but to
sit there and talk about him like he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] the guy made a [ __ ]
rocket he had a malfunction but like I
said sorted sort of NASA numerous
occasions so what are they all dumb at
NASA I don't get it I was [ __ ] amazed
I like when I when I saw that thing take
off I could like thank [ __ ] guy built
that thing it had the balls to get in by
the way nineteen
percent of the [ __ ] that you use
everyday somebody [ __ ] died as they
were figuring out how to [ __ ] do how
to make it happen any sort of
transportation anything that moves
Planes Trains boats [ __ ] anything
rockets the amount of [ __ ] people
that died so your dumb ass that the only
thing you know is what the [ __ ] you read
but you've never [ __ ] you've never
broken any ground yourself go easy on
that guy he's [ __ ] dead have a little
[ __ ] respect for the guy I know you
can make fun of my don't give a [ __ ] if
you make fun of him but don't [ __ ]
talk about him like he's a [ __ ] you
know unless you're gonna [ __ ] on you and
your [ __ ] boring ass life what the
[ __ ] are you doing
why am I talking to guys like you are
all people on that threat I should be
you know I'm talking the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
who trashed this guy natural selection
and you know what's I [ __ ] love about
it if somebody always says that somebody
then it's the exact same [ __ ] memes
any time a name is trending oh my god
thank God I thought the person was dead
and then they got the stupid Denzel meme
how many [ __ ] times can can you do
that before you just like why would I
why would I subject people to this again
unless you're doing it just to annoy
people you know like all the people are
now gonna send me that meme thinking
that I'm not realizing that you're gonna
do that which by the way I never check
my [ __ ] feet anymore this is what I
check it when like occasion I check it
but then I also when I have something
that's coming so if you want to get me
it's it's right after I have something
come out because I do a quick survey I
scroll like two pages and then I just do
the math like alright what percentage of
that was positive okay that sound seems
like it's a good thing all right I
missed the [ __ ] mark on that one or
something but rest in peace steam rocket
flat earther guy I don't know I don't
know what to tell you I could tell you
right now that guy is smarter than I am
you know I I there's nothing I've ever
done in my life that is the equivalent
of what the [ __ ]
that guy did in the last [ __ ] ten
minutes of his life none of you guys are
ever gonna feel that or myself that
level of [ __ ] adrenaline he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he had his own goddamn TV
show this guy's [ __ ] fascinating to
me [ __ ] fascinating why would you
just tap out on he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know he's a [ __ ] amount of people
that text while driving myself included
any moment could take out a school bus
full of [ __ ] kids right a sitting
there calling this guy of [ __ ] [ __ ]
as you drive to work every day what do
you see on the side of the road wreaths
and crosses and frosted [ __ ] bikes I
don't know this isn't all just that this
is also I'm kind of dealing with [ __ ]
show business right now I've been doing
some [ __ ] and I just like just it's not
even show business it's just business
the amount of stealing that goes on and
[ __ ] business it's just it's so
[ __ ] gross so [ __ ] gross and I
swear to god it's always some [ __ ]
155 160 pound [ __ ] little [ __ ]
[ __ ] who's never gotten this [ __ ]
kicked out of in life and now it's never
gonna [ __ ] happen right because this
[ __ ] cameras everywhere
so the [ __ ] beating that this person
should be taking they're never gonna
[ __ ] take I swear to god it's either
that or it's some fat [ __ ] in a goddamn
suit you don't even realize how fat he
is until the company picnic what he
actually has to wear a t-shirt and he
takes off that layers of [ __ ] habit -
arenas big dumb [ __ ] love handles
unreal unreal and you know what business
rewards it rewards those same [ __ ]
people who've never done anything and
[ __ ] on this Team Rocket guy those
people who just [ __ ] just sit there
and don't get themselves killed they
don't have a vision they're not taking
any risk
not leaders that just [ __ ] they're
agreeing and saying what they have to
say those [ __ ] people ascend Oh God
freckles is in a [ __ ] mood today
anyways [ __ ] Celtics and Bruins lost
this weekend Celtics I just had a nice
class another classic game against the
Los Angeles Lakers Lakers winning an
exciting one
I guess Jason Tatum just went off he
hasn't already solidified himself as a
you know the future of the league one of
the guys you know when they [ __ ]
debate who's the best guy out there
looking like he's going to be one of
them which is exciting as a Celtics fan
and then the Bruins got absolutely
smoked by the Vancouver Canucks
disappointing ending to that [ __ ]
Western Canada swing I was hoping maybe
some of the players on Vancouver maybe
they would [ __ ] take the Bruins
lightly and go out the night before you
know and have a bad game evidently not
evidently not [ __ ] nine goals Jesus
Christ
it's goddamn three goals a period and
that's upsets a [ __ ] goal every was it
twenty every [ __ ] six minutes and
seven seconds Jesus Christ can't imagine
all those [ __ ] sticky syrup he [ __ ]
Canadian people's that we think they had
to keep getting out of that chairs for
once it wasn't difficult to get up after
the game they won but standing up nine
[ __ ] times during the game I'm gonna
have to watch a replay of that you know
when you go in the NHL Channel they
[ __ ] they got um you know when you
watch the replay they have like all like
they have like the little dot where a
goal is scored you know what I mean I've
never seen one that had nine dots just
on the you don't know top and the bottom
you know one teams on top ones on the
bottom depending if it their home or
away and you know I've seen four or five
I've never seen nine nine goals I mean
that's just
- [ __ ] ass-kicking unless you're
talking football I guess basketball -
but whatever it's 2 out of the 4 sports
you got the [ __ ] kicked out of you so
whatever it's a good thing so Vancouver
Canucks fans were giving me [ __ ] about
that hey hook it up into the Bruins I
don't know they lost a regular season
game why the [ __ ] would you give me [ __ ]
when we [ __ ] drank from the Stanley
Cup in your building while you were
burning down your city this has nothing
to do with any any any of the [ __ ] that
I'm talking about this has nothing to do
with it it's the [ __ ] mood I'm in
right now and this always happens when I
work too much all right but I got a nice
little [ __ ] you know little full 5
day a little getaway with my wife coming
up that's what I'm working towards
everybody's working for the weekend
that's what I'm working towards all
right and what I'm just gonna realize
you just realized it some some times in
your life your life isn't yours and you
just [ __ ] ride it out but you know
something I had a great time today
though I'll tell you that I went over a
buddy's house and he had a little pizza
party right and a [ __ ] pizza was
delicious he's got a [ __ ] wood fire
thing he made in his backyard then they
had this giant inflatable slide that was
so big that my daughter started going up
it and then decided she didn't want to
do it and I was parking the car of
course doing the dad [ __ ] right so I
came in
lovely Nia tells me she doesn't want to
go up she's afraid I say hey you want to
go up with me she's like all right so
then we went up together I said you want
to go down and just seemed like really I
was even looking at it like god dammit
uh gonna be going down a little fast
here and she was just didn't want to do
it and I said what if I alcohol I know
I'm gonna hold on to you so she goes
alright so we started going down and
immediately she screamed in fear and by
then what then and a half second was
over and then she just laughs and goes I
want to do that again and I think we
went down that thing like thirty times
and I was having such a good time the
look I
gotta tell you man being a dad is
awesome the look of sheer joy on my
daughter's face and then we stopped and
we ate pizza and that she's looking at
me you know afterwards just being like
you know listening you know cuz we had
to get her home for the nap and I was at
you know any time we talked about her
she just looks at us because she knows
what's going on so say we gonna you know
we got time to do it again you just want
to go I don't know but blah blah do we
give her a rice cream then she's gonna
be up she's not gonna nap and I just
like I I'll go again and then I just
looked at I said hey you want to go down
the slide again and she just like eyes
lit up she's like yeah like freaked out
and I said alright five more times which
of course was like ten and I don't know
he's one of those cool moments in life
you have to be experiencing something
and you know and like you know in the
future I'm gonna think about this a lot
how awesome this day was and how amazing
this experience was you know I'm telling
you that's gonna be one of those things
someday when she gets older and gets
married that'll be the thing that I
think about and cried our wedding never
be able to do it's gonna be because of
that right there
just a [ __ ] awesome day you wouldn't
know it from the first [ __ ] 18
minutes but I did I did have a great day
I swear to god man there's nothing
better than there's nothing better than
being a [ __ ] dad and a husband and
then hanging with your family on the
[ __ ] weekend
everything else is [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright ship recruiter everybody I got
one read one all right you know hiring
used to be hard man multiple job sites
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process but today hiring can be easy
take it easy and you have to go to one
place to get it done that zip dot-com /
/ zip sends your job
to a 100 of the web's leading job sites
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your jab you
can even add screening questions to your
job listing so you can filter candidates
and focused on the best ones
[Laughter]
there's the bazillion different ways to
read that into that one zip recruiter is
so affected that four out of five
employees who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
gotta love that time is money and right
now to try zip for free my listeners can
go to zip recruit calm slash birth at
seppuku to calm / / spell it out zi p r
e crui ter dot-com / / zip recruited the
smartest way to hire alright let's get
into some of the others [ __ ] here this
week some of the other stuff here I was
a [ __ ] I was a great dad today man I
felt good about myself you know after
that you know my wife was tired got her
daughter down for the nap you know got
her up [ __ ] cook the dinner gave her
the bath [ __ ] books
I'm tired of [ __ ] but it was awesome cuz
she's getting to that size were pretty
soon she's not gonna want to get picked
up anymore and it's the greatest thing
ever
it's the greatest thing I gotta tell you
I am [ __ ] up my back though putting
her on my shoulders I realized you know
when is his little dad advice when you
go to put your kid on your shoulders
right first of all always make sure
there's like a [ __ ] bed or a couch
behind you so you can abort whenever you
want right so I don't know how big your
kid is but like if you lift them up
underneath your underneath their arms
their armpit see if you pick them up
there then you're gonna when you go to
put them over your head you're gonna
have to duck your head down and duck it
your head down while putting your
[ __ ] arms straight up over it I don't
know what
the one but it's giving me a [ __ ]
backache so now I grab at the waist lift
straight up and then you got to do that
when you go to take them off - it's also
a good way to keep your hat on and not
get it knocked off now that I've been
doing it the wrong way for like a
[ __ ] year I finally like broke down I
probably put two and two together why
does my center of my back bothering me
it's like oh you know I always say yes
every time dad dad I want to write on
your shoulders I absolutely absolutely
every single time is a yes because
someday she'll be too big
she'll be too big and I don't ever want
to be there going like you know I do to
put her on my shoulders more I'm gonna
be [ __ ] walking around osteoporosis
going I did it every time don't you have
no regrets there are my keys all right
guys this this one's gonna I swear to
God next week my life slows down and I'm
gonna have more quality [ __ ] podcasts
but I am under the gun for time here all
right ain't so bad
kind of sounds like Tom pop is special
right you're doing great
which I haven't had a chance to see yet
but I know for people that saw it and
they all were like not only is it is it
it's [ __ ] great it's the best special
Tom pop has ever done and Tom pop is a
beast
so check out his special again if you
haven't already all right yo bill I
agree that some levels of socialism are
necessary ie policemen firemen etc okay
I'll take I don't know what socialism is
I just know that that's what everybody
anytime you want to help somebody out
they say you're a socialist
all right capitalist wouldn't be so bad
if our currency wasn't constantly [ __ ]
with I agree I don't understand how they
do it but inflation before the Federal
Reserve aka families with old old money
the bank cause it's all really one bank
but the Federal Reserve all parenthesis
aka families with old old old money
the bank because it's really only one
bank right okay was 3% after the first
150 years since the Fed took over its
inflated over 2000 percent the dollar
loses 2% of its value a year the stock
market trades on future prices
government votes to allow more ways for
them to rip off the middle class this is
corporate capitalism honest capitalism
would be a fish for a fig and if you
catch a hundred fish you can trade for a
hundred figs because you fished a little
longer what the [ __ ] what you want to
give some fish to someone you know in
need great does the town I live in need
three or four of my 100 fish to help
keep things running wonderful then they
need half the fish I just worked all
weekend two fish criminals okay I see
what you're saying here yeah well my
point about governments why none of them
work is because human beings run them
and just the kinds of people that are
attracted to positions of power a
position of power where you you are
telling other people what to do and they
have to listen to you because they work
for you right does that make sense or
they're under your power of some sort of
a government I just think inherently
like I don't want to do that to people I
don't [ __ ] know why would I want to
tell people what to do I'll give you
some advice I'll give you some advice
I mean I'll do that what the [ __ ] what's
going on I'm playing like nine of them
I mean I'll [ __ ] do that I'll give
some advice here or there but I'm not
gonna where in the [ __ ] did my goddamn
oh there it is I just said I see I tried
to do something slick here and all of a
sudden it all goes out the window
criminals yeah I agree with that
criminals okay no system is perfect
communism is a small group of people
deciding for the masses but isn't that
what's going on in this country
historically it's been a nightmare
please look up the gulag our cheap PO
leggo AR CH IPE l AG oh I would actually
like to read about that communism to
people is what Google is to information
one central system and no way out I
would say it's like LAX one way in one
way and then there's no way out because
everybody's going to the same place
also you've talked about how the super
wealthy buy up all the land and
resources the other half of that coin is
that they own all the ports overseas
shipping is still as important as it's
been since the days you read about in
your history books no spices anymore
just laptops cards food and everything
else all right
so we saying the same thing hmm I can't
tell I don't know what the point of that
one ain't so bad I agree with some of
the socials when our necessary
capitalism would be so bad yeah I think
yes I mean yeah it would be great if the
brilliance of how cap our country works
is how underpaid politicians are so
they're susceptible they don't have any
money and then they got to run for
office and they need money and then the
richest people given the money and then
they own the favors and then with each
you know generation they just keep
buying more and more power and get them
to pass [ __ ] that legally gives less of
a [ __ ] about what they're doing
[Music]
you know what are you gonna do I'll tell
you what you're gonna do you're gonna go
down a slide with your kid while you
still kid because it's [ __ ] awesome
alright Joel Olsteen bashing this guy
said I was bashing Joel Osteen I was
being funny just talking about him like
he was a comedian and now he's [ __ ]
brilliant and now he doesn't have to
travel you know he bought an arena and
he sells it out he's a [ __ ] genius is
what I was saying and I make fun of
anybody who's up there acting like they
know what happens when you die nobody
does nobody does you have to die in
order to figure out what happens you
need to die alright but I haven't said
that I don't think there's anything
wrong with believing in a higher power
if that's working for you but like I
kind of reserve the right to just
[ __ ] make fun of [ __ ] I mean that's
all I'm doing here I'm not saying don't
go anyways dear Billy Bible basher um
I'll be honest with you that was the
[ __ ] old me alright I went through
you know a lot of dark Pierce I don't
trash women the way I used to like so
much of that [ __ ] it's just me you know
I don't know what the fun maybe you're
right maybe there's a religion that's
actually right out there I don't [ __ ]
know alright I know it's fun to rag on
Joel and he makes an easy target but I
think you should at least be accurate
with your jabs no I shouldn't
not nothing I'm saying on this podcast
is [ __ ] accurate this is just me
[ __ ] going off on [ __ ] this is like
if you were [ __ ] in a goddamn bar and
there was some guy in a [ __ ] rant and
you're gonna sit there and fat check him
I'd say that he can't blow off steam
while he's having a [ __ ] bear in a
shot I'm just [ __ ] around here I
think that you know something's funny is
I do this to every single topic out here
but you're into Joel Olsteen or you're
into religion so now this is [ __ ] you
know twist in your [ __ ] undies here
alright I see lots of people spreading
lies about him as if it was Dick Cheney
oh and if it was Dick Cheney I could
understand but I'm not sure why he
deserves
level of hey well would Dick Cheney he
didn't have to spread any lies he could
just say what the [ __ ] the guy was doing
all right and I didn't I don't have I
spread any little but lies that I spread
about the guy I've just [ __ ] tased
him that's all I'm saying I want to
[ __ ] buy an arena and never leave
town he was first of all he doesn't
collect a salary from his church
he's rich because he's written multiple
selling books all right that's not
accurate
that's not accurate dude his [ __ ]
sermon is on television there's
commercials he's getting paid just cuz
he [ __ ] papers the room and gives
that gives it away you can show up for
free is that what it is I don't know
I'll tell you right now buddy if it's on
television he's getting paid he doesn't
collect a salary from his church oh my
god oh that thing yeah so he doesn't
have to pay taxes Jesus Christ dude
that's one of the oldest ones in the
book and not the Good Book either the
bad book anyways I've actually read one
of them and it was an inspiring book
with a positive message I can see why
some people might not like it or would
find it cheesy but it wasn't mine Kampf
nobody said it was mine comfortable.i I
didn't say it was I don't know what
you're talking about in a second who
cares if churches don't pay taxes I do
how come they don't have to pay taxes
but I do he goes you know who else
doesn't pay taxes Amazon and Walmart
it's well no this is all well known sir
that's like who cares if this guy rapes
you know who else rapes at least the
church is going to use some of the money
to do something good for the community
well so does Amazon and Walmart they are
always having [ __ ] charities to talk
about you know to make up for the fact
that they have guys driving 18 wheelers
17 18 hours of [ __ ] day but does your
government but what does your government
do with your tax money besides bomb
little brown kids to protect those poppy
fields in Afghanistan here we go Jesus
no there we go
what else do they do well they also
repair bridges what that they give a
little bit of money I mean you kind of
like in agreement with me and you're
like giving me [ __ ] like I don't realize
that our foreign policy is a little
perverted all right
third he didn't open the compact Center
during the hurricane because it had a
history of flooding during hurricanes no
Jesus Christ
well if you're buying all that other
[ __ ] why wouldn't you buy that oh okay
I've chased hurricanes all along the
Gulf Coast for years I was in Houston
during Hurricane Ike I saw the condition
on the ground when things got bad it
takes a lot of people to run an
emergency shelter especially when it's a
former basketball I don't disagree with
any of that and most people are busy
sheltering with their families at their
own homes i dude I get it I get it okay
but I got to tell you something let me
ask you this okay if you had a [ __ ]
arena and you're super [ __ ] famous
would how hard would it be to reach out
to the National Guard and say hey I'm
offering my stadium my arena if you want
to use it if you can provide me and I
can get some volunteers down here
whatever I mean dude and I wasn't even
talking about that I was talking about
him like he was a [ __ ] comedian
anyways I don't go to church every
Sunday and I'm not a huge fan of
religion so I'm starting to feel like
Joel Olsteen wrote this but I will admit
that during a really dark time of my
life
his sermons actually helped me out oh my
god this guy's like guilting me here
when that inner voice was dry ok I'm not
reading the rest of this sir or ma'am I
was saying I was envious one of the
deadly sins I was envious isn't one of
those deadly greed gluttony Brad sloth
Morgan Freeman
that was just saying okay having being a
part of a corporation okay that doesn't
pay taxes and then you don't take a
salary is a double [ __ ] like you've
you've shrink-wrapped yourself into just
completely not paying taxes oh I don't
mean take a salary the corporation
doesn't [ __ ] let me guess so he
doesn't take a cell he makes all his
money on books the [ __ ] out of here okay
if you want to believe that one all
right I beam yeah okay all right all
right hey maybe maybe you're right maybe
you're right baby maybe you're right
maybe that's exactly he doesn't he
doesn't take his salary why doesn't he
take her salary
ask yourself that is it because he
doesn't want to pay individual [ __ ]
taxes or because he gives a [ __ ] that
much I didn't even want to talk about
this [ __ ] I was just saying it was this
[ __ ] that he bought his own [ __ ]
arena I have no problem with the guy
I don't good for him and where do those
taxes go most of them go to a [ __ ]
bank that acts like it's part of the
government that isn't okay I mean can
you really steal from people that are
from thieves I don't know I guess you
can I don't [ __ ] to it you really
just took all the fun out of this I was
just [ __ ] around jesus [ __ ] christ
next time somebody gives me [ __ ] about
one of my [ __ ] bits should I sit
there and be like you know I actually do
a lot of benefits for troops and people
with with fatal diseases you know I
actually let me ask you you good [ __ ]
and I pay taxes it's fun literally his
[ __ ] sermon is on television he's
trying to tell me he's not making any
money off of that he just broadcasted
for freek is that what you're telling me
coronavirus story I don't buy it
alright coronavirus I'm
not concerned about that because I never
enjoyed that beer thank you I'll be here
all week
coronavirus well it's definitely not
scurvy they stick that little lime in
there don't they
yo oh my god that is Corona beer all
upset like Jesus Christ why couldn't
they call it [ __ ] Budweiser virus yo
Billy coincidence toes I've read some
articles with some substantial ideas
implying that China unleashed the corona
virus to keep Hong Kong in order
yeah well this always happens whenever
some [ __ ] like that's happening I
imagine other people have talking have
their Bibles out and they're talking
about locusts people in the streets
fighting for their freedom are now at
home hoping not to catch the virus
unrelated I bought a house in the middle
of nowhere with tons of trees and a
stream for not a lot of money I'm 43 and
retiring in three years
can't wait to escape the office and any
potential viruses well that's well wait
a minute can you please write back and
let us know what you did for a living
you're gonna retire at 46 I want to know
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
[ __ ] do I gotta tell you right now if
I was 46 again and I retired and I
wasn't married and I didn't have any
[ __ ] kids and I'd have to have a
companion me and neo was still
boyfriend/girlfriend I would [ __ ] I'd
have the grill going and I began to thaw
up and what do you guys think about this
like this this is a way to go out
alright now that we started off with
that guy dying in his own steam [ __ ]
rocket if you do that you buy a thing in
the middle of nowhere right
you retire in your mid-40s and you just
[ __ ] party yourself to death okay you
still have a house you still have money
you know I could be out in the street
sucking dick to try to get another
[ __ ] you know pack it a [ __ ]
whatever right
you got your own money you drinking
top-shelf booze you got some great weed
he got some great wine all right you're
eating steaks
you know the Surgeon General's calling
you let the Machine take it I mean I
don't know there is something to be said
to going out that way
don't listen to me people I'm just
dealing with the fact that I've gotten
rid of all of these [ __ ] vices and I
don't know what to do about it man I
don't know what the [ __ ] to do about it
get more people write in about retiring
like this is [ __ ] amazing she bought
a house in the middle of nowhere with
tons of trees and a stream for not a lot
of money I'm retired I'm 43 and I'm
retiring in three years I don't want
that to be true I hope I wish that right
I that option for every person on the
[ __ ] planet
I just know I would go out of my mind I
love doing what I do too much I had so
much fun by the way up in Vancouver
thank you guys for coming out I got to
do four [ __ ] shows up there I had
such a great time and I don't know what
happened to my act like I thought I had
the brand-new 90 minutes or whatever I
115 90 minutes back in September and
like I feel like 40% of that just left
and all this other better [ __ ] just took
place of it
I'm so [ __ ] excited just to get
through this month and then [ __ ] get
back out on the road and do some goddamn
dates and just to see the direction that
this thing's gonna head it I really
[ __ ] like in my act right now so I'd
like to retire at 70 though or just at
70 be like fine you know be able to do
whatever the [ __ ] I wanted to do
would be cool and then just be cool walk
around be a cool old guy walking by
young people I like your music good luck
in life I hope you find love just be a
positive guy all right dog troubles all
right so check it out I need some advice
I've been dating this girl for a couple
of years now and it's going great except
for one thing
her dog she has this awesome dog that
she has had for years way before she met
me she says the animals saved her life
she talks about how this dog really
understands her and is a huge emotional
support for her the only problem is now
that we have moved in together the dog
sees me as the Alpha and will only
listen to me bill it's driving her
[ __ ] nuts oh my god that's hilarious
she gets so pissed because she will try
and to prove that it's still her dog and
try and make the dog choose between us
and the dog always comes to me always
jumps on on my side of the bed at night
I mean this dog even sits outside the
bathroom while I'm taking a dump holy
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] hilarious she can't
stand it this is what blows my mind is
if I had a dog and then Nia moved in
with me back in the day and that
happened I I would I would see the humor
in it I wouldn't give a [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] dog well this is what she get
for [ __ ] trying to have in a human
relation with a goddamn animal anyway
she can't stand it now she's telling me
I should be do doing more than more
doing more to help her get the dogs
loyalty back and then I am sabotaging
her relationship with the dog I don't
know what she wants to do wants me to do
I'm not gonna treat the dog badly it's
an awesome dog it's not my fault I'm
bigger and I have a beard and feed the
dog and take her on walks she sees me as
the pack leader so I told her she just
got to step up her game anyway tell me
what you think I think that that's
exactly what
you should tell her what you just said
you know you moved in and she stopped
[ __ ] I guess she was obviously doing
that [ __ ] when you weren't there yeah
there you go
just be like yeah I would least think so
what do you want me to do be mean to
your dog what are you talking about like
there's plenty of videos on YouTube that
talk about how to be the alpha [ __ ]
presence in the house do that now
[ __ ] follow your log you know [ __ ] I
think I want to be out there every
morning in my [ __ ] PJs picking up
[ __ ] [ __ ] dog [ __ ] in a plastic bag
thought I was doing you a favor by the
way how about a [ __ ] [ __ ] every
once in a while it all depends on how
far you want to take it sir anyways PS
when are you gonna come up to Alaska
I've only been there once I played
Chilkoot Charlie's way back in the day
in the late 90s thanks to Doug Stanhope
he hooked me up with the gig the closest
I get to comedy is when Marc Maron talks
about how I used to live in Anchorage I
didn't know that come on up here with
the lovely Nia and your wonderful kid
and see some of the amazing glaciers
before they are all gone I'm a boat
captain so I can get you guys out there
on the water to see how wild those
Alaskan salmon really are
that's [ __ ] then it's goddamn
tempting alright oh Jesus look at this
[ __ ] question to vaccinate or not
dear Billy freckles my wife and I are 31
and 30 years old and have our first kid
in June I'm from Boston
was a Marine officer and completely
vaccinated for everything she comes from
a poor highly religious family in the
south and is not vaccinated at all oh my
god needless to say she doesn't want our
new baby to get vaccinated either well
we did that with our kid and our kids
fine that's [ __ ] insane
not to do that there's a reason why
vaccines came out it was because kids
used to die all the time
her parents are nice people but they
have filled her with misinformation over
the years just the other day I heard my
mother-in-law say that our four-year-old
nephew has trouble speaking annunciated
because of the vaccine
his parents decided to give him this has
been debunked a bunch of times I can
sympathize with the distrust of powerful
institutions even though I'm a
Vanderbilt MBA who did in an internship
at Amazon I definitely agree with your
rants about corporations in the food
industry however I think we've taken it
too far in this country second opinions
are common in medicine but there's not a
single reputable doctor who will tell
you not to get your kid vaccinated I
know he [ __ ] crazy much like
listening to sports hacks who have never
played the game half the people in the
country insist on giving medical advice
Kent contrary to all the people who
actually went to [ __ ] medical school
well there's your argument right there
sir just say you you get me a [ __ ]
reputable doctor that says you're right
and I will do that and this is my kid
too and my kid is getting vaccinated my
kid is not gonna get [ __ ] polio jesus
[ __ ] christ
I read that most of them most of the
people not back he's vaccinating our
super rich [ __ ] and misinformed
working-class people the exact groups of
people that have given us our current
politics that's the error
oversimplifying and I think to 24-hour
new air-quote news networks that are not
even remotely unbiased okay and
deregulating everything and allowing
super rich people to buy up any amount
of TV radio and newspapers and magazines
they can own as many they used to not be
able use to be a rule of 7 you couldn't
own more than 7 in a market or total I
can't remember what because you could
influence public opinion from someone
who doesn't trust institutions but
believes in science what do you think I
should do I think that you should you
should
that's your [ __ ] kid too and this is
this [ __ ] thing out there when they
sit there and they act like women have
no power ok because I can tell you this
right [ __ ] now that if you're a guy
and you don't wanna get your kids
vaccinated but the mod does the kids
getting vaccinate
all right 99% of decisions go the way
that the female wants in the house
because it's her way or the [ __ ]
highway that's basically it you're gonna
have to deal with her [ __ ] emotions
that's it that's it so you just cave but
you can't cave on this one and it's just
like who are you listening to your
parents I love your parents they're not
doctors
all right let's let's go down to a
[ __ ] Hospital let's go to the best
Hospital in the country let's go there
or the best one in our city and let's go
there and let's ask them and see what
they say okay and if you can find me
some [ __ ] information contrary to
that to somebody who's actually a
[ __ ] Delia you know what you probably
will be able to because there's always a
couple of [ __ ] nut jobs out there
yeah I you know yeah there's it's your
kid too buddy so stand your [ __ ]
ground stand your [ __ ] ground
that's it all right that's an easy one
all right what is it easy is I have to
[ __ ] in this podcast a few minutes
early here because I have to be up here
in another [ __ ] couple of hours yeah
get your kids vaccinated and then
[ __ ] put the kid on your shoulders
your healthy kid on your shoulders and
[ __ ] go to the playground and slide
down the slides and [ __ ] run around
and [ __ ] wrestle and just just have a
[ __ ] great time being a parent is
[ __ ] awesome
all right don't [ __ ] it up by letting
your kid get the [ __ ] bubonic plague
all right god bless all yeah and Joel
Olsteen I don't have anything against
the [ __ ] guy I was just teasing the
guy that's it I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] that he doesn't pay
taxes if you figured out how not to do
it god bless him I don't give a [ __ ]
okay he made all his money selling books
Jesus Christ I should write a book huh
Jesus Christ
anyway sorry that's it I don't get into
this [ __ ] all right
they have a wonderful couple days
everybody and I'll check it on you on
Thursday and go [ __ ] yourselves but not
Joel Olsteen because he's a great guy